[Music]
baby backs
my powers will become yours
[Applause]
[Music]
that's crazy right what are your
superpowers superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing
hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please is Kathy Sparkle
fingers no it's not it's nobody that's
not my name Joe's work Oh like a bad guy
you really did the opposite of what a
superhero supposed to do you're him
you're the hero
you're welcome for not getting robbed
I want you basically 15
[Music]
yeah you electrocuted a bus and almost
kill these people and then I caught it
and they tall buildings in a single
bound
everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend I want
you to meet four key he's a spool yes
yeah I know four key is the most
important toy - Bonnie right now we all
have to make sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was they pursued salad maybe chilli
and then the trash but we gotta get
forking over it
why am i alive
you're Bonnie's toy you are going to
help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life huh come
on bow-bow hi my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy
what are you doing here no time to
explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff Woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow woody
are we going to Barney we have to find
only two but what do you do jump out of
a moving vehicle
let's go where you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can
because you can't teach this old toy new
tricks you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're coming home for you
but my way whatever with vanity
kids lose their toys everyday I was made
to help a child I remember it being this
hard buddy somebody's whispering in your
ear
[Music]
Gussie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man
[Music]
the last I loved you and we said a
little more surprises but I was really
hoping to pull off one last one
the world has changed
or we can do it is our best and
sometimes is the best that we can do
sonofa
[Music]
I saw all these people die
I keep telling everybody they shouldn't
move on
someday Alanis
[Music]
a small chance
oh this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
heretics
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
I like this one
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the land
[Music]
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty to wishes three I'm
kidding rush
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is
all out of gray area in make me a prince
I could just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
Showtime no I'm in charge okay I say
when it's done really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
to my right is bounty law series lead
and jake cahill himself Rick Dalton and
to my left is Rick's nut devil cliff
booth so Rick explain to the audience
exactly what it is a stunt double does
actors are required to do a lot of
dangerous stuff cliff here is meant to
help carry the load is that how you
describe your job cliff what carrying
his load adds about right
[Music]
my hands are registered as lethal
weapons we get into a fight
I accidentally kill you I go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in a
fight to go to jail it's called
manslaughter
[Music]
that was the best acting I've ever seen
in my whole life thank you you have no
idea what's coming mr. Witt broke the
rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives you shouldn't be here
nice suit
good to see you too I need your help
after this we are less than even
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
would you help set the mood for our new
guests let us begin
[Music]
our services still off-limits to me what
do you need
guns lots of guns you think you can take
John wick you got a nasty surprise
coming
I've been looking forward to meeting you
now for a long time and so far you
haven't disappointed
we can keep this up as long as you'd
like but this only ends one way
[Music]
all of this for what because of a puppy
was it just a puppy
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated who kind of saved the
whole island anyway war with Leonard in
the pigs what are you gonna do I'm a
foodie still going on those what and Bob
and Chuck are doing whatever they do I
eat dirt and me well I still have some
anger issues but I'm finding healthier
ways to deal with it I know we've had
our differences but we've discovered
that there's a third island maybe one
good reason why I should believe you now
show you the proof will Tim really
repent this is a hundred times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver we just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing what we're gonna break in
and deactivate the weapon we was amazing
we can't get that key card hello fellow
Eagle God how he's doing a voice yeah
I'm just gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mom Who am I
you are a gift
we believe that you came here for a
reason
I know it's been difficult for you
lately but bet you feel different from
other kids
Caitlyn get mando he's a creep help me
Mom I wanted in handcuffs and I'm what
I'm going do you even know who is real
lovers i miss your mother
let's go
maybe there is too long Brandon
turn against ourselves he's not
[Music]
he was messing with me
[Applause]
something wrong boy round by chance you
are the only people in the world that
knows how special I am they are believed
to be no survivors
268 passengers on board
[Music]
Oh No No
whatever I know there is good inside you
I wanted you good man
I do well he ever given you
well you recall your falling sound court
sivappu since I seen Pentonville for
example chimayo job is you're watching
me harder
what a Lambo hurt you wash your car ye
[Music]
mr. Charlie
[Music]
how's this sound if you break something
I can fix it I have a school for young
people who are like Eugene we could be
your new family if you like go qureishi
where is she
she should be dead whatever happened up
there made her stronger she's changing
it what
I'm scared I mean is control bad things
happen to people I watch I'm not giving
up on Yugi this is what family does we
take care of each other so that power
destroyed everything that ever came into
contact with
until you
oh they don't understand they fear
and what they fear we seek to destroy by
you scared little girl who answers to a
man in a chair are you the most powerful
creature on the planet so colossal
this is your fault Charles tell me how
we fix this trust tell me what to do
don't know what to do
girl dies she's still Jean we can still
help sometimes you want to believe
people are something that they are not
ready time you realize who they are
it's too late
she's coming
[Music]
since childhood I have been fascinated
with language I've invented my own you
invented an entire life [ __ ] yes I made
stories legends tell me a story in any
language you want stop jealous
the journeys we take to prove ourselves
spoken functions we should form a club a
brotherhood changed the world
through the power of art music poetry
and what about talking I want to write
something it's about magic beyond
anything anyone is gonna thought before
what it means to love to be loved
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
we all of the wisdoms at language had to
tell you mr. talkie but never come
across anything like it
this is more than just a friendship it's
an alliance an invincible alliance a
[Music]
fellowship
[Music]
hey Jenny oh that's some strong for lung
I contact so we're gonna bounce
they were together nine years I thought
we could handle anything until I
actually just got a drop in San
Francisco I just don't feel like I'm
ready to leave New York beautiful before
and after pitches right now oh I gotta
kill you okay basically I just really
want you to call your place of work and
tell them you have your period or
something and they just call over my
apartment you know the beginning of a
disaster movie like right before the
girl who looks like me dies and like
right when a girl who look like you walk
outside and be like oh my God look how
crazy this guy looks this feels like
that I leave in a week and then I turn
30 and then I die probably I need one
last epic day with Mike Ross
[Music]
but you holding me back
I am deeply obsessed with us right now I
can't even ever say like this this is
the end of an era everything's changing
I mean we're out here take it R if you
have a girlfriend
whatever kindly leave your
heteronormative labels and a
[ __ ] box
thank you making choices you still have
that boyfriend you hate oh I'm sorry was
just goofing around
yes this just can't be where it ends
this is destiny you are Beyonce
I love you guys for real
our best friend is out there drinking
champagne from a bottle of green juice I
just want to scoop her up and make it
all go away
wait it's the green juice mimosa yes
I feel better I'm gonna pick them up
[Music]
[Applause]
Christina says that you've got some
special thing planned
yeah it's like a crazy nine-day festival
it only happens every 90 years
[Music]
hi you can't speak
he kept moving
but this opens you up to taking French
it breaks down your defenses
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna love it
[Music]
Secretary of State Charlotte field of
the United States of America
[Music]
so were you like dating the Prime
Minister of Canada no no no it's weird I
know this great little place not too far
from here
oh it's called a mini bar and it's in my
room you ass
no hey I put up with my fair share of
world leaders to 369 Fidel Castro once
you thought his beard was big so how
does that work with you to like date
guys don't really want to date women who
are more powerful in them that's a big
shrimp their dicks Tripler is my
favorite bambam bill with no so you can
ask why I'm still single
just breathe we're seconds in
the optics of you and Fred would destroy
your entire career it's pretty woman but
she's Richard Gere and you're Julia
Roberts got destiny on your side ah I
feel so scared I'm gonna try to conduct
myself in such a way that does not risk
winnable humiliation she bought me this
[ __ ]
it's a traditional Swedish suit Oh
another [ __ ] sweet dressed like this
I'm the Smurf down we're gonna [ __ ]
suit next time
[Music]
right I need you to come work on that
speech with me right now
am I being too bossy no no he'll do
exactly what you are imagining and then
you turned me around slap in my house
and took me a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
it all happened so fast
we have to stop them Batman
whatever they are they're going to
regret stepping foot and Gotham
this is our big score gentlemen get the
baton fire fire
do I look like a friggin bat to you
[Music]
I've read rumors about a supernatural
back creature in Gotham but I assumed it
was an urban legend Ninja Turtles
we came to Gotham to stop shredder and
the Foot Clan
[Music]
we'll help us destroy this city is right
behind this door
[Laughter]
Robin Batgirl these inmates were the
deadliest criminals in all of Gotham
let's move
it's time for this destroy himself take
him down
we need answers you're welcome to try he
thought too fast
[Music]
we're not your enemy this is still my
city
if they're ready for a fight we bring on
a freakin fight
you want to know max for me let's end
this
[Music]
feeling like a failure or life pass you
by I can't take any more rejection honey
you remember Kevin Wow so what's your
plan now that you've been kicked out of
school
I've taken a temporary position and a
public relations firm did you always
know this is what you wanted to do or
did you want to do another thing first
like did I dream of figure skating but
my parents wouldn't pay for the lessons
you don't want to be a temp forever do
you get got a letter for you get ready
you ready for what
[Music]
you have come to the store Kiptyn and I
am the salesman behold we sell what you
need unicorns
there was the only thing I ever wanted
if I have one brought here I have to
know that you're for real I've made a
decision
I'm building a home worthy of you
unicorn let's teach me something like a
stable I don't think a pony wants to
live in your basement it's a good point
do you think this is some kind of joke
should we just get you a puppy I know
that I'm just a disappointment or always
like why don't you a boyfriend or why
are you just more like Kevin Oh someone
call me no don't know how to be a grown
up my parents think that I'm insane I
mean what is really going on this is
crazy
the most grown-up thing you can do is
fail at things you really care about you
need to learn to love you soon get out
there show us what you can do
you got that
everybody needs some magic in their
lives even if they're all grown up
tell me where does this unicorn come
from the unicorn star oh of course
[Music]
let me break it down welcome to the
Institute of perfection
remember only pretty dolls will meet
their perfect human match engineer slash
model boy Dolph model do you honestly
think your little band of sock puppets
stands a chance you it's probably better
if you just go back where you belong
are we really not good enough for the
big world you know what we're not going
anywhere our flaws make us who we are
oh they're all worth fighting for
Davina sake won't you hard pass ooh ooh
ooh another swing isn't that right
gibberish cat
nothing is gonna stop us now leave him
the loft cause he's gone forever I am
over here there's nothing we could have
done you do know that Lou is gonna make
it super hard for you well I say bring
it on Louis
oh my doll
[Music]
[Music]
specialist Lucy time to wrap it up we're
going home
go Polaris is go you're all green
[Music]
liftoff from 10
nine just feel a little off eight go up
there you see seven the whole universe 6
and everything here looks spot
they're so small three
got to see the vast celestial everything
and Blue Boy
now nothing makes sense
[Music]
Lucy I'm fine
[Music]
I've always wanted to date the most
popular girl drive the nicest car and go
to the fanciest school Yale is the gold
correct more than anything in the world
but I can't afford any of that back
who's paying me to escort my cousin
who's semi-formal I'll take you cousin
what I'll take your cousin to the dance
why what would you get out of it I get
the payment you were talking about and I
get to take your car you got a suit
[Music]
you're getting paid to take a girl on a
date did you know that Michelle Obama
got paid to go on a date with Barack and
look how great that turned out is that
true I don't know but it could be true
and that is my point
[Music]
good evening let's do this so we can
stop doing this we don't care what you
say I happen to think that you and I
could have a really good time tonight
you've clearly never been to a high
school let's go shred some hardwood
[Music]
this is your job no should be troubled
rich girls and Eva Schaffer it could be
big business here I figured out how to
get the money I need to go to Yale I'm
offering my services as a chaperone
from whatever it is that girls one hey
oh my god you didn't oh but I did every
date would be custom-built they could
pick my personality my interest whether
I'm a listener or a talker what's the
weirdest part I had listened to this
girl talk for four hours straight all I
was allowed to say was there is no other
way to see it oh my god that is the
perfect date there's no other way to see
it can you imagine if I get enough money
to get into Yale and date Shelby hey
it'd be my dream come true they're just
waiting for people to accept you instead
of accepting yourself you act so tough
just an ass we used to spend time
together
but I guess you'd have a new bridge
Prince
I don't know which version of myself I'm
supposed to be how she's a really bad
dancer yeah she's the worst I've been so
many people these past few months a
cowboy an art connoisseur and a bad
friend it's time to figure out who I am
and what I want what are some of your
interests outside of school
howdy usual teenage stuff
yeah
I've spread my dreams under your feet
tread softly because you tread on my
dream right I'm in a single income
household and Jen and I just had our
second baby I think it's time for a
raise I can't give you a raise it's like
giving a raise to a drug addict my
child's like a drug problem
you're fired you're fired obviously oh
you must be McCreary oh wow you're fired
she's coming back back who are you I'm
my I'm a new writer don't sit down okay
could you sit down please I'll just use
that trash can it's comfortable better
than everyone I came to tell you this
year is your last what they can't
replace you if everyone loves you then
none of you understand what is at stake
here
I am being replaced think about why the
show is bad and come up with ways to fix
it I wish I was a woman of color so that
I could just get me Java while we talked
about this you can't say that I know
what everyone thinks that means but just
because I was lucky enough to get this
job doesn't mean I'm stupid enough to
listen what exactly is wrong with my
bids you're a little old sin a little
wait what can I do about that I have
some jokes with my log I shouldn't do
this in an English accent should I know
what this is your show it's an
expression of who you are
how would you describe Molly she thought
I was the vibrant splash of color on the
gray canvas of our writing staff I mean
I need you only I need your pushiness
and lack of boundaries you left me no I
didn't say that
I know I mean hat indoors worried but
you know I didn't say it in any of those
words
[Music]
[Music]